le 23 avril
1671 le prince invite à chantillli son
cousin le Roi Soleil pour 3 jours de
fête alors comment va réagir celui qui
condamne à mort quiconque lui fait de
l'ombre il y a 2000 personnes c'est
vraiment l'un des principaux événements
à chantil du vivant du grand Condé c'est
l'époque où les jardins sont en grande
partie terminé et donc il va accueillir
son cousin lui montrer son domaine mais
en lui indiquant que toute cette
magnificence est faite pour lui fin
stratagème le Grand Condé laisse le roi
croire qu'il a transformé chantillly
pour lui le roi ses
merveill le grand con des
savours je ne sais pas si vous imaginez
les fait que ça a pu faire à Louis XIV
quand il a été invité par le Grand Condé
en pleine nuit ça marchait il allait le
soir ça marchait il allait le matin ça
marchait c'est c'est un les fait devent
être saisissant pour lui quand même et
grâce à tous ces jeux d'eau avec grande
réussite d'André Le nôre en cela chantil
dépasse versaill définitivement le Grand
Condé probablement en son fort intérieur
prend un peu comme une vengeance face
face au roi pourquoi
pas les années passe les générations se
succèdent à
Chantilly mais la rivalité avec
Versailles
continue même après la mort du Roi
Soleil les travaux Versailles se sont
arrêtés net à ce moment-là et tous les
ouvriers se trouvaient un peu sans
grandchose à faire et donc le prince à
chantil le prince de conier a dit
écoutez les G moi aussi j'ai un château
VI venez chez
moi cette nouvelle main d'œuvre va
changer radicalement le visage de
Chantilly à commencé par les façades du
grand
château on a changé toutes les parties
haute donc il faut imaginer des sortes
de grandes tours et puis au sommet on a
placé des lanternons on a placé des
toitures on a ouvert complètement les
murs par un très très grand nombre euh
de
fenêtres les modifications se
poursuivent à l'intérieur c'est le cas
dans le petit château devenu entre-temps
le lieu de vie des princes de
Chantilly on va créer une grande galerie
comme la galerie des
glaces avec les mêmes dispositifs
c'est-à-dire que vous allez avoir des B
qui sont les B de la Renaissance qui
vont être agrandis réaménagé et de
l'autre côté on va obstruer les baai de
la Renaissance pour y placer des miroirs
de sorte que la lumière des BA va
pouvoir se refléter sur les miroirs
placés juste en face comme dans la
galerie des Glaces de Versailles donc
c'est un petit
versaill mais là où le savoir-faire de
ces ouvriers versaillais va être mis à
rue d'épreuve c'est dans la construction
à chantillly d'un nouveau bâtiment qui
va battre tous les
records
I